hi schön dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet
habt zu ZDF heute live ich freue mich
darauf mit euch zu sprechen und zu
diskutieren wir sprechen hier heute über
ein Thema das gerade richtig viele
Eltern in Deutschland beschäftigt und
zwar den Notstand in deutschen
Kinderkliniken durch Europa geht gerade
eine Welle von Atemwegserkrankung und
die sorgt dafür dass die Lage hier in
Deutschland auf Kinder Intensivstation
katastrophal sein das sagt z.B Professor
Dr Florian Hoffmann von der deutschen
interdisziplinären Vereinigung für
intensiv und Notfallmedizin und was das
genau heißt das hat sich Sybille Basler
für uns angeguckt
anna hat Leukämie 6 Monate war sie hier
auf der onkologischen Station heute wird
die zweijährige entlassen doch in die
Freude mischt sich auch die Angst ihrer
Eltern wenn wir zu Hause sein und
müssten dann herzwegs Fieber dann wissen
wir nicht ob wir hier auf der Station
aufgenommen werden können weil die
Betten reduziert sind die Sorge ist
berechtigt denn wegen Personalmangel
können auch hier viele Betten nicht
belegt werden seit Monaten und das
trifft die kleinen Patienten mit voller
Wucht das bedeutet dass wir hier in der
Onkologie
unsere Kinder nicht mehr versorgen
können also wir können die Familien die
wir lange lange kennen bei uns auf
Station zum Teil nicht mehr aufnehmen
kein Einzelfall dazu noch die massive
rs-viruswelle das bringt die Kliniken
bundesweit in große Not jedes zweite
Krankenhaus muss kleine Patienten
wegschicken weil es kein freies Bett
mehr hat so eine aktuelle Umfrage und
der deutschen intensiv und
notfallmedizinern die Lage ist höchster
dramatisch denn wir müssen den ganzen
Tag überlegen eben wenn da ein Bett ist
welcher Patient bekommt es und welcher
eben auch nicht ein Notruf aus den
Kinderkliniken langfristig plant Berlin
die Abschaffung der Fallpauschalen und
eine 300 Millionen Euro Spritze schnelle
Hilfe in der aktuellen Misere soll unter
anderem durch verschobene Ops geleistet
werden und die Kinder brauchen unsere
volle Aufmerksamkeit wir werden Personal
aus den regulären Erwachsenen Stationen
in die Kinderstationen verlegen
insbesondere Pflegepersonal und Anna sie
und ihre Eltern dürfen jetzt nach Hause
sie hoffen nur eines das bloß nichts
Unvorhergesehenes passiert
ja über die Situation in den
Krankenhäusern über Karl Lauterbach und
die politische Dimension des ganzen
darüber möchten wir heute sprechen und
darüber wollen wir auch mit euch
sprechen wenn ihr Fragen Anregungen zum
Thema habt dann stellt uns die wir immer
gerne ihr könnt mitdiskutieren gerne
hier im Chat oder per Mail an ZDF heute
- live at zdf.de und jetzt begrüße ich
zum einen dr Beatrix Schmidt sie ist
Sprecherin des Verbands leitender Kinder
und jugendärzte und Kinderchirurgen für
das Land Berlin herzlich willkommen bei
ZDF heute live und wir sehen da ist noch
ein anderer Gast ich begrüße da muss ich
einmal hier auf meinen Zettel gucken ich
begrüße auch noch einen weiteren
Gesundheitsexperten er ist
Bundestagsabgeordneter der Grünen und
gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher seiner
Fraktion herzlich willkommen
schön dass sie heute schön dass sie
heute bei uns sind ich würde gerne
einmal wissen Frau Dr Beatrix Schmidt
wie ist denn die Situation gerade in
Berlin wie müssen wir uns das so im
täglichen Business vorstellen
also ich kann nur sagen dramatisch und
zwar in allen Kinderkliniken die in
Berlin existieren es ist eine große
Welle mit dem sogenannten rsv-virus und
das Problem dieses Virus ist dass es vor
allen Dingen kleine Kinder betrifft also
Kinder unter einem Jahr die wenn Sie
dieses Virus bekommen Sauerstoff
benötigen oder auch eine Atemhilfe oder
Gabe werden das heißt sie brauchen einen
intensivplatz und sie brauchen
Pflegepersonal und natürlich auch
Ärztinnen und Ärzte die sich um dieses
jeweilige Kind kümmern
Pflegepersonal ist rar es gibt einen
riesenmangel im ganzen Land an
Pflegepersonal und dazu kommt dass die
Viren natürlich auch nicht vor
Erwachsenen halt machen das heißt der
Krankenstand ist relativ groß und die
weniger Menschen es gibt umso weniger
Betten gibt es die betrieben werden
können in den Kinderkliniken
ja danke für diesen Einblick in ihren
Alltag gerade lassen Sie uns einmal
gemeinsam auf die Zahlen gucken wir
haben da nämlich Zahlen von der divi von
der deutschen interdisziplinären
Vereinigung für intensiv und
Notfallmedizin auf Kinder
Intensivstation gibt es in ganz
Deutschland nur noch 83 freie Betten
rechnerisch weniger als eins pro Klinik
jeder zweite der 110 Befragten Häuser
muss Notarzt wegen wieder wegschicken
überall fehlt es an Personal
ja auf der Politik gibt es ja dazu
gerade Reaktionen und jetzt hat der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach gestern so eine Art fünf
Punkte Plan vorgestellt mit dem er jetzt
Abhilfe schaffen will Herr Damen was
sagen sie denn zu diesem Vorschlag von
Karl Lauterbach der sagt ja zum einen
das gucken wir uns auch gleich noch mal
im Detail an dass Pflegepersonal oder
generell Personal von den
Intensivstationen auf die
Kinderintensivstation verschoben werden
sollen
ja zunächst mal ist die Situation wie im
Beitrag dargestellt ja wirklich
automatisch man muss sagen dass die
Besonderheit in der Kinderheilkunde und
gerade auch in der Kinder
Intensivmedizin ist dass das natürlich
keine einfachen Tätigkeiten sind die
einfach jeder Mensch der im
Gesundheitswesen arbeitet übernehmen
kann und insofern schmerzt das gerade
jetzt in dieser Belastungssituation dass
wir den speziell ausgebildeten
kinderkrankenpflegekräften und
denjenigen die dort dann auch noch eine
Spezialisierung für die Intensivmedizin
haben nicht genug warten ähm es ist
allerdings so dass wir insgesamt sehen
müssen dass natürlich auch einer Station
in einer solch dramatischen Situation
wie wir sie jetzt bewältigen müssen
immer auch Arbeit anfällt die nicht am
Patienten stattfindet sondern wo es
beispielsweise um administrative
Tätigkeiten geht um betreuende
logistische Tätigkeiten wenn für
Nachschub mit den gesucht werden muss
und hier Pflegekräfte auch zu entlasten
durch
Gesundheitsfachberufe aus anderen
Bereichen das ist sicherlich in der
absolut dramatischen Situation in der
sich viele Kinderklinik Finden eines von
vielen Instrumenten was man heranziehen
kann um die Situation gemeinsam jetzt zu
bewältigen
Frau Dr Schmidt sie haben gerade schon
so leicht das Gesicht verzogen was sagen
sie denn zu diesem Vorschlag
also ich gebe Herrn Damen völlig Recht
dass man sicherlich Pflegekräfte durch
zusätzliche Einstellungen von ganz
anderen Berufen entlassen kann die
administrative Dinge übernehmen damit es
viel mehr vergeben im Kinderkliniken
oder generell im Krankenhäusern weil die
administrativen Aufgaben in den letzten
10 20 Jahren massiv zugenommen haben
nicht nur für die Pflege auch für die
ärztlichen Mitarbeitenden aber das eine
erwachsenenpflegekraft ein Kind
versorgen kann das würde ich einfach
nicht unterstützen wollen ich denke das
erwachsenenpflegekräfte eventuell große
Kinder versorgen könnten wenn sie dazu
entsprechend angeleitet werden aber das
was wir im Moment haben ist ja eine
Krise mit den kleinen Kindern mit denen
unter eins und dazu brauchen viel
Fingerspitzengefühl viel Erfahrung und
vor allen Dingen auch eine gute
Ausbildung
ja ich habe da gerade schon mal so ein
bisschen angeteasert was unter anderem
in dem Lauterbach Plan so drin ist aber
vielleicht lohnt es sich wenn wir da
noch mal kurz im Detail drauf gucken was
gerade der Plan der Politik ist
Krankenhäuser sollen ihr personalaus
regulären Stationen auf die
Kinderstation verlegen dazu werden
Krankenkassen aufgefordert die
personaluntergrenzen vorübergehend nicht
mehr zu überprüfen
Kinderärztinnen und Ärzte sollen
erkrankt auch weiterhin telefonisch
krankschreiben können nicht notwendige
Vorsorgeuntersuchung für Kinder sollen
wenn möglich um wenige Wochen verschoben
werden
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach weiß
zudem auf die Möglichkeit der
telemedizinischen Beratung hin Eltern
könnten somit von zu Hause eine
medizinische Beratung erhalten
langfristig sollen die Probleme auch
durch das am Freitag verabschiedete
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz
angegangen werden dadurch bekommen
Kinderkliniken in den Jahren 2023 und 24
zusätzlich jeweils 300 Millionen Euro
ja wir haben es jetzt einmal bildlich
dargestellt bekommen das sind die Pläne
der Politik mit diesem Problem gerade
umzugehen Herr Damm ich frag mich jetzt
helfen diese 300 Millionen Euro wirklich
zum einen werden sie ja erst nächstes
Jahr ausgezahlt wir haben jetzt eine
konkrete Krisensituation und gehen diese
300 Millionen wirklich auf das größte
Problem in der versorgenden Versorgung
nämlich diesen akuten Fachkräftemangel
haben sie völlig recht das gibt von der
Füller ein Problem mit denen wir jetzt
gerade in den Kinderkliniken
konfrontiert sind natürlich einige die
mit Geldschein nicht lösen lassen aber
was keine der Kinderkliniken im Moment
gebrauchen kann ist dass sie zu dem
Fachkräftemangel zu der viruswelle die
gerade passiert auch zusätzlich noch in
wirtschaftliche Existenz bekommt und
deswegen war es wichtig dass wir heute
mit einem Beschluss im Bundestag dafür
gesorgt haben dass ab dem ersten ersten
20 das sind ja keine vier Wochen mehr
zusätzlich 300 Millionen Euro für die
stationäre
Krankenversorgung im Bereich Kunde zur
Verfügung stehen denn sie müssen sehen
ein Punkt an finanziell Hinterlassung
neben vielen anderen Dingen die auch
viele Kinder kriegen die hohen Ausgaben
die viele Krankenhäuser im Moment
leisten müssen um über zusätzliches
leitpersonal Leasing Personal
beispielsweise im Bereich der Pflege
sich Fachkräfte heranzuziehen um die
akute Situation zu kompensieren und
gerade solche entstehen im Moment ganz
stark und in erheblichen Maße und dafür
unter anderem auch zusätzliches Geld
bereitzustellen das war ein wichtiger
Schritt aber im Übrigen nicht der
einzige den wir heute beschlossen haben
denn neben diesen zusätzlichen Geld ist
beschlossen worden dass wir ein
personalbemessungsinstrument für die
Kinderkrankenpflege auch extra eins für
die Kinder Intensivstationen einführen
werden was dabei helfen soll in Zukunft
den spezifischen Bedarf an
kinderkrankenpflegekräften in diesem
Bereich frühzeitiger zu ermitteln und
gegenzusteuern wenn die Pflegekräfte
fehlen und als dritten wichtigen
Baustein in dem heute beschlossenen
Gesetzes außerdem erhalten dass es
zusätzliches Geld gibt wenn hoch
spezialisierte Kliniken in der
Kinderheilkunde
telekonsellarische Beratung für Kliniken
die eher eine generelle
allgemeinversorgung machen
durchführen und sich so Kinderkliniken
gegenseitig helfen und das bringt mich
von diesen Mittel und langfristigen
Maßnahmen eigentlich zu der akuten
Situation und ich würde den ja Schritten
oder Vorschlägen die dann Minister
gestern vorgestellt hat vielleicht
hinzufügen wollen dass in der akuten Not
das wichtigste worauf es jetzt ankommt
ist dass wir gut koordinieren wo die
wenigen verbliebenen Betten die es für
die Kinderheilkunde im Moment noch gibt
dass man dort steuert zwischen den
Kinderkliniken dass
klar ist dass jedes Kind was ein Bett
braucht auch regional oder notfalls auch
überregional auch ein Bett bekommen kann
und gerade in Berlin
verschwindet das noch besser erklären
können haben sich die Kinderkliniken
jetzt in den vergangenen Tagen
zusammengeschlossen und übernehmen
solche Steuerungsfunktion zentral so wie
wir das in der Pandemie auch bei alten
Patienten oder moderaten gucken in
anderen Bereichen mit dem Coronavirus
machen mussten klar ist das ist alles
nur Notmaßnahmen die für den Moment
helfen und diese langfristigen Maßnahmen
die wir heute beschlossen haben müssen
erst wirken dazu werden auch weitere
Form gebraucht die gerade den
Fachkräftemangel und die
Weiterentwicklung der
Kinderkrankenpflege ganz besonderen
betreffen
ja Dankeschön Herr Dahmen ich höre
gerade sie müssen los aus Termin Gründen
danke dass Sie bei uns waren bei ZDF
heute live ich freue mich aber mit Frau
Schmidt noch kurz weiter zu sprechen
nämlich genau über diese Vorschläge die
wir da gerade gehört haben wir hören 300
Millionen Euro das klingt erstmal sehr
viel sollen ab 2023 zweimal pro Jahr
also einmal in 2023 einmal in 2024 in
deutsche Kinderkliniken fließen wie
bewerten sie denn diese Maßnahme und wo
muss aus ihrer Expertise dieses Geld
hinfließen damit es auch wirklich hilft
also generell ist ja zu begrüßen dass
die Kinderkliniken die bisher rein an
ihrer Wirtschaftlichkeit gemessen wurden
im diage-system jetzt zusätzliches Geld
bekommen sollen das würde ich denken
begrüßen alle die mit Kindermedizin
etwas zu tun haben was man aktuell
machen kann
Herr Damen sprach von Leasingkräfte es
gibt keine Leasingkräfte mehr der Markt
ist komplett leer gefegt
könnte man überlegen ob man jetzt
vorübergehend einfach mehr ÄrztInnen und
mehr Ärzte einstellt auf die stehen kurz
vor Burnout und gerade in den zentralen
Notaufnahmen wäre sicherlich
empfehlenswert wenn es schon zu wenig
Pflegekräfte gibt das ist dann zumindest
dort mehr Ärztinnen und Ärzte gibt ich
glaube auch dass man das Geld gut
investieren kann in Berufe die der
Pflege und auch den ärztlichen
Mitarbeitenden zu arbeiten
mittelfristig denke ich
dass man den Pflegeberuf einfach
attraktiver machen muss man sie müssen
sich vorstellen es gibt keine
Kinderkrankenpflege mehr dieser Beruf
ist mehr oder weniger abgeschafft es
gibt nur noch die sogenannte
generalistik mit der Möglichkeit einer
Vertiefung im letzten Jahr oder einer
Spezialisierung wenn man eine
Spezialisierung hat auf
Kinderkrankenpflege kann man sich am
Ende
kinderkrankenpflegefachkraft nennen was
allerdings EU weit nicht anerkannt ist
aber Berlin und das als Beispiel zu
nennen bietet bietet diese
Spezialisierung nicht an das heißt
Berlin
zur Zeit bildet keine
kinderkrankenpflegefachkräfte mehr auf
das wird dass es den Beruf praktisch
nicht mehr gibt wurde von allen
Fachgesellschaften
als sehr schlecht wahrgenommen aber die
generalistik als einzige Möglichkeit
wurde trotzdem eingeführt abgesehen
davon ich denke auch mit einer guten
Vertiefung kann man am Ende gute
Kinderkrankenpflege machen aber man muss
die
möchten und der muss einfach attraktiver
werden ich glaube dass er bessere
finanzielle eine bessere finanzielle
Bezahlung von Nöten ist eine bessere
Wertschätzung ich erinnere nur an Kobelt
wo alle auf dem Balkon standen und der
Pflege applaudiert haben das hat ihm
glaube ich nicht so viel genutzt und ich
glaube auch dass dieses was im Moment ja
passiert wo Mangel ist wird mal eine
Pflegekraft eingesetzt ich glaube dass
das den Beruf nicht
so gute kommt weil jeder der in einer
Klinik arbeitet möchte ja in seinem Team
arbeiten also auf der Station wo er oder
sie eingearbeitet ist mit einer
Wertschätzung von den anderen
Mitarbeitenden und wenn man immer
springt und woanders arbeiten muss dann
glaube ich macht einem der Beruf auch
nicht so viel Spaß
wir haben es eben gehört ja die
Kindermedizin oder die Pflege im
Kinderbereich ist noch mal ganz eigener
Bereich jetzt ist aber diese
Pflegeausbildung wie es Frau Schmidt
gerade gesagt hat generalisiert worden
und da denke ich sofort auch an zum
Beispiel dieses Fallpauschalensystem
also das System mit dem man berechnen
kann wie viel Geld ein Eingriff einem
Krankenhaus bringt mal so ganz einfach
erklärt wie sehen Sie das denn da soll
ja jetzt auch rangegangen werden mit
Hilfe dieses neuen Gesetzes was sind
denn die Herausforderungen in dieser
Kindermedizin die das da schwerer machen
also was sind die besonderen
Herausforderungen die eigentlich die
Behandlung von Kindern erfordern
das kann man eigentlich einfach
beantworten Kinderkliniken haben erstens
viel mehr Vorhaltekosten wir müssen sich
vorstellen wenn ich ihnen Blut abnehme
dann nehme ich ihn gut ab fertig wenn
ich einem dreijährigen Kind Blut abnehme
brauche ich noch mindestens zwei weitere
Menschen nämlich eine Person die das
Kind die den Armen festhält und die
zweite Person die die Röhrchen anreicht
das kann nicht alleine nicht managen das
heißt das Personal ist viel mehr und
viel aufwendiger im Kinderkliniken dazu
brauchen Sie natürlich Menschen die im
Umgang mit Kindern gut
sind Kinder haben Angst im Krankenhaus
und besonders kleinen Kindern kann man
nicht erklären was mit ihnen passiert
das heißt sie brauchen ihre Eltern das
heißt wir haben pro Patienten nicht nur
einen Patienten das Kind sondern auch
immer noch die Eltern mit denen wir gut
und verständnisvoll umgehen müssen weil
Eltern haben auch große Ängste um ihre
Kinder
und wir brauchen eine gewisse
Sensibilität für die Kleinsten unserer
Gesellschaft im übrigen ja unsere
Zukunft darstellen
ja das ist wohl richtig Frau Dr Schmidt
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns waren und
sich den Fragen gestellt haben vielen
dank vielen Dank und ja
schönen Abend noch ja ihn auch danke
danke und sie hat gerade schon
angesprochen Frau Dr Schmidt die Eltern
die spielen natürlich eine riesen Rolle
bei der Behandlung von Kindern wenn
Kinder ins Krankenhaus kommt und wie
deren Situation aktuell aussieht das
gucken uns jetzt mal an
der kleine Timo und seine Mutter haben
es in Hannover am eigenen Leib erfahren
wie es sich anfühlt wenn Deutschlands
Kinderkliniken an ihre Belastungsgrenze
stoßen
wir waren letzte Woche schon hier in MH
weil es eben schlecht geht und ja da hat
man uns nach Minden geschickt man hat
gesagt hier wäre alles gesperrt ganz
Hannover ist dicht Minden wäre die
nächste Stelle abgewiesen das kommt
immer häufiger vor
zu viel brauchte da waren wir im
Deutschen Herzzentrum da war es auch
ganz schön mit dem die haben die die
hätten die Kapazitäten da die könnten
jeden Tag viel mehr Kinder operieren
aber die haben halt nicht das Personal
und die Betten dazu betreuen die Betten
an sich sind also nicht das Problem auch
an Ärzten mangelt es nicht es fehlt das
Pflegepersonal mit dramatischen Folgen
deswegen sind Kinderkliniken geschlossen
worden sind Stationen geschlossen worden
und Betten abgebaut worden und das bei
steigenden Fallzahlen wir haben mehr
Kinder die wir in den Kliniken Behandeln
mit weniger Betten und das führt uns
jedes Jahr wieder an das Limit letztes
Jahr war schon schlimm und dieses Jahr
ist es fast noch schlimmer immerhin die
Versorgung der Schwerstkranken sei aber
nicht gefährdet
ja das sind wirklich irgendwie
ergreifende Bilder die wir da gerade
sehen mir ist jetzt zugeschaltet
Professor Jörg er ist Direktor der
Kinder und Jugendmedizin an der
Uniklinik in Köln herzlich willkommen
bei ZDF heute live
und wenn ihr da draußen Fragen habt an
Professor Jörg Dötsch stellt gerne diese
Fragen bei uns im Chat oder schickt sie
uns per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de Herr Professor Jörg
sie leiten ja eine Kinder und
Jugendmedizin am Uniklinikum wie ist
denn die Situation bei ihnen gerade
gehört es ist so dass wir alle Kinder
die schwer krank sind behandeln das ist
auch wichtig dass die Eltern das Wissen
dass die Familien sich sicher sein
können dass schwer kranke Kinder immer
gut behandelt werden auf der anderen
Seite sind die
Umstände unter der viele Kinder die
vielleicht nicht so schwer krank sind
unter die Familien sehr lange warten die
sind natürlich jetzt schon sehr
unangenehm das ist auch so dass seine
Familie sechs bis sieben Stunden wartet
bis sie behandelt wird vorausgesetzt das
Kind ist nicht so schwer krank es kann
durchaus sein dass eben in den Beitrag
gehört dass wenn es dann nötig ist im
Krankenhaus zu bleiben das ist nicht die
Klinik ist in der man sich vorgestellt
hat sondern dass man in eine andere
Klinik verlegt wird und das Wasser auch
für viele Kinder und Eltern natürlich
eine schwierige Situation ist dass man
vielleicht über Wochen oder Monate
vorher einen Termin für eine stationäre
Aufnahme für einen kleinen ein
ausgemacht hat und es wird kurz vorher
abgesagt weil es eben keinen verfügbaren
Bettplatz gibt das ist also sehr
belastend auf der anderen Seite dient es
dazu dass eben schwer kranke Kinder
behandelt werden können
ja also vielleicht ist da gerade auch
Rücksicht gefragt und ein bisschen Blick
fürs größere Bild wenn uns jetzt hier
vielleicht Eltern zuschauen wie sollen
die sich denn gerade am besten ganz
konkret verhalten wenn Ihr Kind krank
ist
ganz wichtig ist wenn man schon
Erfahrung hat und merkt es geht dem Kind
vielleicht morgens schon schlecht dass
man versucht es nicht bis in die armen
Stunden zu ziehen damit man sich
sozusagen nicht in der Notaufnahme ist
vorstellen muss wo ganz viele andere
Familien möglicherweise bereits warten
das einfachste wäre sich dann zu dem
eigenen Kinderarzt oder den letztlich
Arzt Vertrauens zu begeben
auch da wird man mit Wartezeiten rechnen
auch da sind natürlich Überlastung zu
sehen aber es ist noch besser steuerbar
es ist noch während des Tages und da
sind dann noch mehrere Menschen und
viele Praxen eben geöffnet wenn man sich
wenigstens sicher ist wenn man nicht
weiß ob man überhaupt zum Arzt ist gehen
sollte wenn man vielleicht auch gerade
sein erstes Kind hat dann ist es auch
sehr sinnvoll sich mit Freundinnen mit
Nachbarn mit der Familie zu beraten wie
wird die Situation von Menschen
eingeschätzt die bereits Familie haben
und dann kann viel mehr beurteilen ob
man sich doch in der Praxis begibt
Wir haben hier gerade eine Frage aus der
Community und zwar von Youtube Userin
Anker und sie fragt können Eltern den
Staat auf unterlassene Hilfeleistung
verklagen wenn sie abgewiesen werden
würde es was bringen wenn viele das tun
also das spricht auch schon gewisser
Frust aus der Frage können Sie uns das
beantworten
darauf zu steuern und daran arbeiten
dass alle Kinder eben gut behandelt
werden und dass wir miteinander da auf
solidarisch sind
es wird keine unterlassene Hilfe
Leistung stattfinden ich möchte auch
wirklich noch mal betonen der Staat
insbesondere das Gesundheitsministerium
wir haben uns jetzt gehört und auch die
Parlamentarier haben jetzt sehr sehr
viel unternommen in schweren
Krisenzeiten um gerade die Kinder und
Jugendmedizin zu fördern und das ist
eben auch wichtig denn Politik kann
nicht innerhalb von wenigen Tagen oder
Wochen riesige Probleme lösen das werden
wir in den nächsten Jahren gemeinsam tun
müssen und in der Zwischenzeit werden
wir die wir in den Kliniken in den
Praxen arbeiten egal welche Berufsgruppe
wir haben gehören alles tun damit die
Kinder so gut wie möglich behandelt
werden
ja sie raten also vor allem zur
Solidarität mit anderen Eltern in
Deutschland den es vielleicht gerade so
geht wenn wir vielleicht noch mal einen
Schritt zurückgehen wir sind ja jetzt in
dieser großen Welle von atemwegs
Erkrankungen woran liegt denn das dass
die Situation gerade so akut ist wie ist
die begründet
wir haben über die letzten 20 Jahre sehr
viele Betten in der Kinder und
Jugendmedizin reduziert haben leider
auch viele Kliniken schließen müssen
unter wirtschaftlichen Druck
gleichzeitig sind insbesondere in den
letzten 10 Jahren die Geburten
angestiegen und trotzdem sind die Betten
zurückgegangen jetzt kommt die weitere
Verschärfung dazu im letzten Winter
schon und in diesem noch stärker dadurch
dass viele Pflegekräfte wie ein Beruf
hoffentlich nur vorübergehend verlassen
haben und das ganze wird von einer
infektwelle jetzt sozusagen getroffen
diese Situation wird dadurch verschärft
das eine infektuelle kommt die
vielleicht etwas stärker ist als sonst
noch durch einen gewissen Nachholeffekt
den es nach der Pandemie gibt aber
solche Infektionen hatten wir auch in
der Vergangenheit schon
sie sind dann eben auch bessere
bettensituationen auf mehr
Pflegepersonal getroffen und deswegen
wurde es nicht so deutlich dass
letztlich für die Kinder und
Jugendmedizin die Betten fehlen
ja und die Welle über die wir jetzt
gerade sprechen die will wir haben es
schon gehört Karl Lauterbach ja jetzt
mit Pflegepersonal abdämmen das quasi
aus Erwachsenen Stationen auf
Kinderstationen kommt dazu haben wir
auch eine Frage von einer Youtube Userin
von agieren die fragt woher will Herr
Lauterbach Pflegepersonal aus der
erwachsenenpflege abziehen da sind jetzt
schon viele Stationen und Intensivbetten
gesperrt weil auch da massiv Personal
fehlt können Sie da drauf antworten
ja das ist natürlich ganz richtig also
wir haben letztlich fehlendes
Pflegepersonal in allen Bereichen und
ich glaube auch da ist das gleiche was
für die Elterngeld wir schaffen das nur
wenn wir das gemeinsam angehen wenn wir
es gemeinsam solidarisch sehen die
Ausgabe ist es durchaus denkbar dass das
Phasen gibt in denen die Kinderstation
sehr sehr stark belegt sind sehr stark
belastet sind und da kann es durchaus
helfen und wenn es nur wenige
Pflegekräfte sind die vielleicht schon
Erfahrung mit Kindern haben wir müssen
uns ja auch gegenwärtigen 30% aller
Kinder werden nicht den Kinderkliniken
behandelt sondern sind vielleicht auf
allen Stationen oder orthopädischen
Stationen und
wenn da die ein oder andere Pflegekräfte
der Geriatrie in der Kinder und
Jugendmedizin hilft kann das akute
anfangen und möglicherweise ist dann zu
einer anderen Zeit vielleicht im Sommer
wenn weniger Infekt Situationen besteht
auch die Gelegenheit des Pflegekräfte
aus der Kinder und Jugendmedizin dort
helfen wo vielleicht junge Menschen sind
Jugendliche die gerade erst erwachsen
geworden sind ich glaube das ist keine
aber ich bin mir sicher das ist keine
optimale Situation aber gerade in
Situationen in denen wir nicht das
Ideale die idealen Konditionen idealen
Bedingungen finden ist das besonders
wichtig dass wir als Menschen
miteinander zusammenarbeiten und als
Menschen erkennen dass wir uns
gegenseitig unterstützen sollten oft ist
dann geteiltes Leid auch halbes Leid
wenn man merkt dass ein anderer Mensch
ein anderes Team Mitglied oder jemand
von einem anderen Team zu unterstützung
kommt und sei nur
manchmal vielleicht über Gesten über
wenige Minuten oder durch auch Gutes zu
sprechen
jetzt noch mal gerade zur wirklich
akuten Situation haben wir noch einen
besorgten youtube-kommentar bekommen von
Marcin B der fragt kommt jetzt ein
triagegesetz für Kinder
im Sinne der ursprünglichen Definition
bedeutet dass in einem Kriegszustand
oder in einer Katastrophensituation in
wenigen Katastrophe sprechen meinen wir
ähm beispielsweise den Absturz seines
Verkehrsflugzeuges oder eine
Massenkarambolage dann dass man dann
wenn man nicht genügend medizinisches
Personal oder nicht genügend Kapazitäten
zur Verfügung hat entscheidet das
bestimmte Menschen nicht mehr behandelt
werden weil sie weniger Überlebenschance
haben als andere diese Situation ist in
unserem Gesundheitssystem das insgesamt
in auch in Europa und vor allem in der
Welt ein sehr gutes System ist auf
keinen Fall gegeben die Eltern können
sich dessen sicher sein dass wir Kinder
vorziehen die besonders krank sind das
ist auch nötig denn wir wollen ja
Schaden von ihnen abwenden aber wir
haben keine System keine Situation in
der Kinder und Jugend und die wird auch
nicht kommen
dieses Thema irgendwie wir kommen gerade
aus einer Krise wir haben jetzt hier
wieder quasi eine Krise im im kleineren
System die scheint sich so ein bisschen
durch die Community zu ziehen wir haben
hier noch eine Frage von Anker auf
Youtube die auch fragt wo bleiben die
Krisenstäbe pop-up-krankenhäuser
Personal aus dem Ausland bei Corona war
es doch möglich
auch in der Expertenrat der
Bundesregierung der für die
corona-pandemie eingesetzt wurde das
übrigens auch Unterbeteiligung von
Kinder und jugendärztin und Ärzten sind
jetzt zwei Ärzte aber in sind viele
Ärztinnen auch dabei aus anderen
Bereichen und das ganz wichtige hierin
ist dass man sich natürlich wenn man
erkennt dass
letztlich nicht nur Corona ein Problem
ist sondern auch andere Infektionen dass
man sich auch dazu äußert und das hat er
Expertenrat in der Tat getan das hat ja
auch in seinem letzten Stellungnahme
immer wieder aufgegriffen dass er auch
andere infektlagen betrachtet hat und
die Bundesregierung hier bereit
wir haben noch eine weitere Frage
nämlich zur Situation der Ärzte und
Ärztin die ja auch gerade quasi am Limit
arbeiten dazu fragt Rafael g auf Youtube
warum sind die Ärzte in Deutschland so
ruhig und legen nicht mal die Arbeit
nieder unfassbar dass die medizinische
Versorgung so schlecht ist
ja ich kann verstehen dass man das
[Musik]
sich das jetzt einfach bevor ich solange
endlich hier noch gewartet habe auf das
Interview habe ich berichte aus der
Ukraine gelesen von Schichten die für
Ärzte dort eine Woche gehen das heißt
sie gehen eine Woche nicht nach Hause
sie behandeln eine Woche in Kiew in
einer Millionenstadt die wirklich zu
zivilisierten Welt gehört hat noch vor
kurzer Zeit das sind katastrophale
Situation
hier in Deutschland haben eine
ausgesprochen belastete Situation für
die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
aber nicht nur im Gesundheitswesen auch
an anderen Stellen und ich glaube ganz
wichtig ist dass wir uns bewusst machen
dass wir trotz allem noch ein sehr gutes
Gesundheitssystem haben wir haben einen
Gesundheitssystem in den Menschen
letztlich vor vielen Situationen
gerettet werden wir haben eine der
höchsten Lebenserwartungen der Welt und
wir haben den Zugang für alle Menschen
zum Gesundheitssystem ganz anders
erzählen USA ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig dass wir auch das trotz aller
Probleme trotz aller Nöte die hier auch
besprochen sind dass wir nicht
ein schlechtes Gesundheitssystem haben
sondern nach wie vor sehr sehr viele
Möglichkeiten wie den allermeisten
Menschen in der Welt vorenthalten
bleiben
das sind vielleicht noch mal ganz
beruhigende Worte zum Schluss von Herrn
Professor dutsch danke dass Sie bei uns
waren und sich meinen und den Fragen der
Community angenommen haben ich wünsche
dir noch einen schönen Abend
ja ich habe zum Abschluss hier noch mal
einige Kommentare aus der Community
gedankenfreunde auf Youtube schreibt im
Moment gibt es lediglich 83 freie Betten
in ganz Deutschland da wird es mir
mulmig die armen Eltern und Kinder und
ich denke diese Gedanken Teilen bestimmt
super viele von euch und Mister bicke
auf Youtube schreibt kinder sind unsere
Zukunft da gebe ich ihm recht wir
bleiben auf jeden Fall für euch dran wie
sich die Situation in den nächsten Tagen
Wochen entwickelt ich danke euch dass
ihr dabei wart und so fleißig Fragen
gestellt hat ich wünsche euch einen
schönen Abend wir sehen uns wieder bei
ZDF heute live macht's gut